foreign
you've probably heard before
there is nothing to seek
you're already it
but what exactly am I
could there be an absolute answer and a
relative answer based on where I'm at in
my journey
the absolute answer has the tether of
infinity we've never left
the relative answer as whatever we
believe our limited identity to be
and how would one go about making a
transformation in identity
it is as though all contraction is in
our pain
and in order to feel the expansion
we must heal
purging the perception of victimization
ceasing scapegoating no longer able to
blame another
we have to cry
we have to accept ourselves
we have to accept the whole drama
and this is where we find our freedom
finding a spacious identity behind the
character
uniting with the source that gives rise
to all characters
ceasing our obsession with self
amplifying our alignment as the whole
at this point nothing will matter more
than Collective prosperity
meeting basic needs and helping each
other fall in love
but there is no arguing with the Divine
course of the ship
one side of the painting may want to
keep its contraction
do not pry their chains
the other side of the painting can build
new Sovereign villages
one is not better than another
once you reach this point of balance you
sit in the window
on one side is transcendent space
vacuous
brilliant potentiality
on the other side is relative
physicality
drama
The Greatest Story Ever Told
allow everything to be as it is
remaining as the tip of the paintbrush
have fun laugh
love
cherish enjoy
you've never left home